okay hello everyone welcome to another
awesome language design meeting
we have a variety of topics today
starting with a complicated one
about
uh handling
uh
annotations to map
so let's see what do we have here we've
got
so the red in those cases are symbols we
don't have but just showing
we're interested in the
map that's interesting
what would a function like association
select do
what would it do yeah i mean because
it's it's got keys i mean select works
on associations
what does the association map do it
creates an association right
i don't use it very much i i usually say
association of and i just do a map with
with rules oh i use association map all
the time i use it constantly
well i should use it probably i'm i'm
i'm
uh not modern enough let's see what is
it
um
it seems like a better idea than what i
do which is association of map the first
usage here is the good one the second
one
the second one is the evil one but the
first one is the first one is really
useful and i use that all the time too
right gosh i should use that i mean i i
do that in two stages
right
okay
um the second one is kind of just a poor
man's key val uh key value map that you
know association of p-value map
basically
yes
except except presented in a more
bizarre way
yeah
okay but what would association select
do
well i mean i think look there's there's
a table here and and maybe not every you
know slot in the table is filled
yes
i see key replace that's a weird one
because that's going to have all kinds
of key collision issues
well that's like when we talked about
having keymap giving it a merging
function option
yes which seems like a good idea
something like that too yeah
right
okay
so
three components to these variations
which arguments are given to the
function by the way
i mean
the things about map for example like
there are different annotations to map
like for instance
uh you know
avoid applying the function f
based on a pattern
to the thing on the thing that it is
being applied to would be an example of
something that would be you know
certainly you don't transform missings
yeah for example yes or or
i mean clearly you can write you know if
test
you know hash sign otherwise
you know well i mean
i mean what you're suggesting is right
you just map the the operator form of
replace
right the things you want to transform
get transformed
no i i know i know but i'm i'm saying
that that if if all you're trying to do
is transform like that
well okay what you're saying is
maybe i just didn't think of that way of
doing it
um i mean what you're saying is that
what i could do is i could just say map
replace
of
and then the pattern
right so the things you want to stay the
same go to themselves and everything
else and blank goes to f of blank
yeah which is by the way equivalent to
just replace with a level spec of one
list
one right yes
but i mean it ends up being something
like this
yeah
um
which is a little weird but not not
totally terrible again i think replace
it level one is probably a better way to
do that but yeah okay
yeah i guess that's how i would normally
do it i was assuming we had yeah if
you're if you're in the map mindset then
yeah right this
is um although there are there are
several other you know cases where it's
not a pattern but a function like uh
again like there is a pretty common
thing that i end up writing with you
know if missing q of hash exactly right
otherwise
if test of hash
then
hash
otherwise f of hash right i mean we
talked about stuff about doing that
specifically for missing
uh you know making some sort of operator
form thing this is like years ago we
talked about having some operator form
that would kind of or like some
headdressy
no it's just it was just an operator
form that would that would do this
right so this is this is like reverse
supplied i mean that would be something
like reverse supplied of f
um which
so what would this do this would this
would be
um
you know
non-missing applied
of f
of x
do we have uh
uh
an lcc ticket from a couple of months
ago assigned to you christopher about
this i mean there was one thing which
was to extend
missing queue with a second argument
about you know what sort or i guess
failure queue
you know what sorts of things we
consider bad but what's also something
yes there was this is the thing i'm
yeah i mean i haven't
looked at that in a while but i think
that was more than a few months ago that
was like at least a year ago
um
but uh yeah yeah so i think we may have
had something about this so maybe we
shouldn't
launch into another discussion about it
if we're gonna remember where we are
look at the notes uh yeah right
you have the do you have the
ticket number handy for that
i can try and find it too but it'll take
me a second because i don't use jira
very much
268 i believe
okay
okay so so let's go back so i mean
that's one item is it's an interesting
idea
the the um
uh
um
i think this is an interesting idea this
some kind of non-missing applied
headdress i think test applied was the
thing that we talked about before
looking at the jira tickets oh yeah i
remember that now
um
f comma condition
you are right it was created november
2020
yes okay so so i remember i thought it
was you know november as they just had
the wrong november
right right yeah
i'm not sure the name is quite right but
it's an interesting function it seems to
me
i mean it might be nice if it also had a
default you know version basically i
agree doesn't yeah
right which i i think it it um
which would be similar to the confirms
defaults presumably
yes i mean that was the other that was
the other thing we talked about the same
time as this was having a function
that basically is like you know failure
q or missing queue
well actually i think the idea was to
extend failure queue so that it it
detects the same things as as uh confirm
or something like that or at least
having a second argument to failure
queue that would let you detect the same
things as confirmed
yes we should do that
yeah right but anyway this seems like an
interesting function but it isn't the
main thing we're talking about here the
main thing we're talking about here is
this meta map
notion
but
what you're pointing out in a sense is
that there's also meta select and so on
as well
so
you know there's meta data enabled
functions basically
um
and
what we would want is something like
select list comma
and then what would it be it would be
some kind of meta i mean just just to
have a
what would the heck would it be it would
be something like
meta enabled of
the function f with i mean something i'm
just making this up a bit but i mean if
we say f of
hash one hash two and then the meta
enabler
would have as its keys here
um you know expression
and
um position let's say
right well i i mean i think that should
be actually a pure function right
oh you just added the ampersand okay
yeah yeah yeah
right but this is so then the idea would
be
that this is
a
general
headdress could this work
a general headdress
that knows
that is enabled by the outer function
i mean this would be probably an up
value story at first at least i don't
like the fact that that you know
functions like selected map are like
blind functions they have no idea they
just they just blindly are supposed to
use that as a head i mean what if for
example i wanted to make a list of
meta-enabled options you know a meta i
want to make a list where it's
meta-enabled of law method and label of
law et cetera
how would i do that with map or with
select yeah i know that's bad right i
mean but we got i guess you put the
ampersand on the outside actually but
still i mean like they're they're
you have to jump through hoops a little
bit to do it well the question is what
meta enabled on its own would do
up when applied to if if you made the
mistake of thinking select is going to
just apply the meta-enabled function
you know what would that then do what
would that return
it would say it would probably be an
error i mean it's like a throw an
uncaught throw
it only lives inside that environment
honestly
i i think that i mean there are two
cases here right they're two different
there's the question of what gets passed
to the function and there's the question
of what's like the fundamental
behavior of this
uh
you know uh this is right so there's for
example there's parallel or not
there's uh do you wrap the thing in an
association somehow and then there's
what gets passed in like you know do you
get access to the index i think that
whether it's parallel or not that sounds
like it's probably a headdress thing
right because that's just sort of
changing the overall behavior of the
function whether it returns an
association somehow i think that those
should be different symbol name and
those would be different function names
like association map because each of
those is a one-off you have i mean if i
tell you it's a parallel version of
select you can guess what that is if i
tell you it's an association version of
selection yeah this multiple like i
don't know what that could be and then
and in this case about what gets passed
in
i mean is there a reason for this case
that it couldn't be like an option to
map or select or whatever
i mean it wouldn't be the prettiest
thing
but i mean but this look
this case
okay
the alternative the thing we're talking
about here is
perhaps going from
this is basically a
a named
some kind of named argument story
i mean this probably we probably don't
want this case this case is probably
less interesting this case is the
interesting case it seems to me what if
med enabled wrapped the head instead of
the function well that's what i'm
thinking that enable if select
comma
property names
potentially property names if you need
it or if you need to exactly analyze it
right
i mean it probably isn't a position i
don't know whether it whether it can
pick it up correctly to lexically do it
right yeah i think we talked about that
last time that that it should do that
for i mean for performance reasons as
well
right but so then the the the full form
of this might be meta-enabled of select
comma
you know expression
position whatever
but it would be what we would do is we
you know we would try to do that
automatically we tried to fill that in
automatically
what about functions i mean i'm not sure
we have any examples of this but what
about functions that take
multiple uh functions like if you had to
make you know fold pair list or
something like that or maybe not fold
pair list um
you know outer or something like that i
mean
it's hard to imagine how how this would
work without her but if you know do you
understand what i mean yeah i understand
what you mean is would it make all the
functions with i mean it's like a curry
type thing you could potentially but it
gets very ornate to say
meta enable this argument but not that
argument yeah and and also the fact that
different arguments might have different
sets of keys that are available
oh gosh yes
so i i
that that's why it seems a bit strange
to put it on the whole select
well okay so the choice is
i i think it will be harder for people
to understand as a headdress i will say
that
go ahead what are you going to say
right so i thought the point was we want
to sort of give a uniform set of
i mean i think trying to have meta
enabled for arbitrary functions like
outer is just a lost cause
right so my understanding of our project
is we want to sort of give a consistent
set of keys to
you know our sort of core
operating
sort of functions like you know
map replace select
you know maybe some friends thereof like
uh
um
uh
uh
well one thing i'd love to have is is
some
um
the
uh
um
you know in like like for map indexed
uh
one of the things i'm always frustrated
by is having to say first of hash two
all the time and i would be much happier
if i could say hash index or something
instead of that
well like if there's a hash
index and then separately there's
another hash something rather that's
like the yeah that's like assumes it's
it's depth one and stuff yes that's what
i'm thinking yeah sure
the um
that would be consistent with how
nearest and take largest use the key
index
yeah just an unwrapped number right
exactly and and would that still be
available even if you're mapping at
levels other than one why not it just
means it's the first level index
okay or the current level index or the
current level yes we'd have to figure
that out um i'd guess that current level
is probably probably more useful but
yeah yeah unwrapped
current level index
so okay i mean in another world
this can't work but it might be nice if
you could just do map
and then you know it it just looks at
the map and oh you didn't use hash one
hash two you used hash expression
okay you know i know how to fill that i
mean unfortunately i don't think that
can work because you're mapping over a
list of associations
you're you're doomed but
right yes yeah well and
you know also if you you map
i mean i suppose
i suppose it would have to find the
things but right you know there are you
can also just map f and maybe f
eventually does something with these
things
well no that doesn't make sense
never mind yeah yeah no i mean i think i
think whatever solution we have i think
it would be it would definitely i think
would be best if you if you don't have
to write the keys that you want right if
it just lexically finds them
you know and then it can be documented
under map you know or or maybe if we
have this other head you know what the
um
you know what keys work
yes
i think well okay so
first question is how many functions i
mean you know if we if we're just
dealing with map
if we were dealing with maps select
replace i maybe
but i think there are many more than
this there are many more kind of
functional programming functions or list
manipulation functions right yeah yeah
so so the one the name i couldn't come
up with earlier is map thread how does
map thread fit into the story
god knows i mean this is
i think there are many more functions
here go ahead go ahead
i have the impression that this can be
generalized to something that looks at
its
wrapper
and finds a position in itself so that's
that's this proposal in the last section
of position applied oh
well
so
so i was trying to to to generalize
um i don't know
splice and threaded this type of thing
and so we can have something this is
just a name for a wrapper
that knows what to do by itself and then
of course if it's placed in the first
argument of map then it can do more
intelligent things
what does it do by itself
it's it
did you can evaluate that the the
um
a value in the first line
and then you see what df does by itself
that's kind of neat
so it's a bit like the idea of nothing
it looks at
at the wrapper head and then it says oh
i'm going to
place myself
replace itself
exactly so it knows that it has to pf
positional plate of f knows that it has
to look at the position it is and then
adds the position
and so if you map that function it
already does what map index does but but
how does it do it at the second level
does it work
not this one but map could add the
position so the idea is that
if it has a wrapper that knows what to
do with it it will do a more intelligent
thing otherwise it still does something
that may be useful in some situation
so for example look at what replaced us
with it in the next example
i think that that's interesting
sorry where is this the did this echo
work evaluate that's echo where
and so you see we just map that
and it's able to return the same thing
but in the process it's saying
i have found this integer here
yes
so i mean we could imagine potentially
okay we could imagine a family of these
things so it could say you know for
example it could be say index supplied
would give you the unwrapped
thing so it would be say index supplied
there
so map index level one map indexed would
be map of index supplied f comma list
well following your previous idea it
could be meta applied and then in a
second argument you say what needs to be
added
maybe the index the position or
right right the general case might be a
matter applied right
of this comma
and then certain metadata
which could be accessed either
positionally i mean you could have you
can have a mechanism to either say that
you could do this
yeah you could have a bank of things
that you could access positionally here
or you could have something where it
defines that that's hash one and
something else is hash two and so on
well so
go ahead well i was just going to ask
back to what italia was saying earlier
about map thread though i mean
because in map thread you kind of have
to be able to use you know hash hash and
stuff like that
so there's sort of a question of
i mean maybe there's one that's just
called like hash
expressions or something like that which
gives you like a list
it's a little bit inconsistent with how
method otherwise works where it gives
you sequences and stuff but
i don't know
um okay
okay so hold on let's let's go back here
this is a very interesting idea
um
so
okay so the this
why do we not so in select for example
it would be select
of um
you know range of 10
and then there it would say position
applied
of
now how would this work
it's position applied
i mean you need a function that looks at
two arguments so even q would not be
useful here but
right but so in that case what would be
is something like
hash
one greater than
um
well actually this would be a bad
example but let's say
uh let's say random
i mean this i don't think this will work
right because
um
no i said something like that right but
i mean the idea would be that it would
be something like this
right
right
that's really nice
[Music]
uh
so but hold on so this is basically just
the
you know it's one of the
it's basically just just one of the keys
in this
meta applied thing yeah right but i mean
so probably one would have for
convenience one would have some special
functions like position applied or index
supplied
um
and then there will be a general meta
applied where you could specify some
whole collection of keys
right
but the main issue is
what does the ambient function like
select
okay how does it know
i mean is this something that the
evaluator would ultimately have to know
because the evaluator knows and this is
going to come up in our discussion of
multi-computation for those who are
joining that tomorrow
um this whole question about
during evaluation what do you know about
what environment you're in
because right now evaluation is context
independent
other than up values which are the only
kind of way that it can see context so
to speak
if there is a function you know it just
doesn't this this will be our first
serious departure from context
independent evaluation
which i think is something we're going
to need go ahead i mean there are lots
of up values i i mean there's stuff like
nothing and splice
i don't know i'm not sure this is the
first departure well fair enough but
it's one that it's more extreme
departure because it really used it
really uses like the position
information
and i could imagine
go ahead you could also imagine though
that you know in the implementation of
select that it just checks oh is my
second argument oh [ __ ] position apply
and that's that would do an equivalent
thing so i don't know that this is
really such a fundamental well all right
but fair enough but i convergent i could
imagine something
where there is
uh i i mean i think i don't know i think
is nick here if nick is here he might be
able to comment on this i rather suspect
that a lot of things we've written that
involve
uh you know replace list for example
would be a good example of something
where you know if you have a replaced
list
and you say something like you know
um
x triple blank why triple blank
goes to
x y and you do that
on
you know range of five or something
that's going to give us a whole bunch of
lists right
but knowing this may not be the best
example
this isn't the best example it's
something where
being able to annotate
in this case it's rather obvious because
they're just but being able to annotate
at what position a replacement was
actually done
which otherwise we just don't know i
mean if you say slash dot right if you
have some expression
f of g of x
and you know g of y or something
you just say slash dot
you know g of
uh know something like this
those things absolutely do not know
where they're being applied
right in other words that that thing
that u squared is context independently
generated here
like how would you write this code
with anything like replacement so that
it knows so in the position applied
world
what this would presumably turn into is
something where you could say
now how would this work because this is
a replacement rule
it's not a function
so i'm saying we want some nikolai
merzin has something in the function
repository that's called multi-replace
that's similar to this
contains all the strategies and it can
act on subsets and tuples independently
like at multiple positions
and it knows about the positions well it
doesn't know it's like tries every
combination but if you want like a
particular set of positions then
you have to come up with some different
design
this is an older version but i think
okay so this one
okay so that's basically just looking at
all possible uh
parts
in that first expression
so this is essentially something like a
meta
this is what we've been calling
something like a meta replace
except that here instead of a function
being applied so we've got a bunch of
functions like map and select that apply
functions we've got other functions that
are in the replace family that that run
replacement rules
right this is how association replace
indexed or something based on the names
that we saw earlier right but the
question is how would you feed in
to a rule like this
how would you feed in
you know to a function it's fairly
obvious that what you're doing is
i don't quite understand how you would
add
sorry it says go back to the echo world
example
that i had before so i think what i
would do is to have the function in the
second argument now of rule
and then the function there is the one
having to know where this has been used
oh i see what you're saying
the problem here is that this works like
sequence the function has a tendency to
evaluate inside rule immediately
and so we have the same problem of
sequence that we have to use some sort
of delay mechanism and that's why i use
this intermediate symbol echoer
well but why isn't this
because by by evaluation
um yeah i understand that it would up
value up even in the rules delayed
exactly i would say i'm in the second
argument of somewhere so it's a bit like
the difference between sequence and
splice
so we need something that only evaluates
inappropriate places
yes
i mean by the way i do think we should
generalize splice to work to be able to
specify the head in which it evaluates
yes as a second argument i'll i'll do
that that should be easy okay
okay but but so then this has the same
issue
and you're saying there'll be an uh
collection of functions in which i mean
one problem with sequence is we never
sort of curated the functions in which
we want it to what we have in a sense
we've hacked with sequence hold we've
basically specified which functions we
wanted to evaluate and which ones we
don't
right
i mean that's the hold all complete also
disables
uh sequences
[Music]
um okay but but let's look here what do
you have here
there
okay that was what we were talking about
before
keys for this
that's what we were talking about before
yeah talking about
okay
okay but but so let's take a look at map
function arguments
so this is the option
[Music]
idea of christopher's
yes
again i mean it's it's it
yeah i am i don't like the name i like
that but
i mean this is the issue is that you'd
like it if you didn't have to list
you know
if it could just detect the argument so
otherwise it's such a p you know it's so
redundant it's like you're saying you
know
map of
f of uh expression comma index you know
an expert and then immediately after you
say oh and by the way the keys i need
are expression and index so it's kind of
like you know
yeah you should be able to i think it
should be a headdress of the f i think
this is crazy
i think this is one of these things
where you know in a big piece well i'm
not a headdress right a rapper no a
rapper of f a rapper of f because
otherwise what's going to happen is you
have a piece of code where f and expert
are both long somewhere way at the end
you've got some weird option setting it
just doesn't seem right
i mean this is something which you know
about at the time when you say oh i
really want that extra thing to be
available inside my f
so possibly it makes it available one
other option which which is what uh
which is what a lot of other languages
do is they effectively have a wrapper
around the expert right so something
like uh
you know a lot of languages have like
enumerate like i think uh python has
this as well where it's like you have
your your sort of iterator object or
list or whatever and you say enumerate
of it and that produces this other
iterator
that you know every time you you you
know ask it for the next to give you you
know the index and the object okay uh
this is the options case so we've got
we've got the case here which is um
we've got the case where it is
uh
wrap the f
which is
map of position applied
of f comma x bar
and then we've got
the other case which is wrap the extra
okay so that would be so the concept
there would be although
conceptually i see so so then it would
be something like um
positionally
well positionally
um so so i think the idea is i i don't
know what you'd call it right okay if
you want to
position
well but the idea is that that sits
unevaluated maybe you could say normal
of that and it would turn it into a big
listy thing
but otherwise it would sit unevaluated
right
yes
and then it would
make but you see then then what this
would do the conceptual thing this would
do is it would turn it into a1
or a you know let's say let's just say
a1 if it was a indexified thing right
you know something like this
at which point then
we still have the problem that map
uh
well well aura could do this or it could
um
in a more general case if it wasn't
position five it was you know i don't
know what to call it instrumentify it
would turn each element into an
association where it says expression
arrow this index zero this etc meta
saturate
meta-saturate sure what would that mean
i have no idea what any i mean this is a
very hard to name concept i think well
it may not be so hard to name i mean
this is a
um
this is add metadata okay so meta if i
and then this that's an interesting idea
so then what it does is
it meta-ifies that to turn it into the
association
list
uh you know x expression goes to a this
is a good idea this is a
i mean it's a good conceptual idea at
least index goes to one etc
right by default on the first level
but it could have a level spec
probably yes
this is something actually that's a
little horrifying the level spec issue
you'd like it to align with the level
spec of map
right so so that's right i mean this
works great at level one but i don't
know what happens when you're mapping at
multiple levels because you just will
change the level structure of the
expression
um this is similar to another idea we
have discussed called cordina ties
do you remember this discussion that we
have an array of quantities and we want
to say the positions because each one is
at your position or a date or something
yes
what did we do with that
um i mean it it's on the works um but
the idea would be
that um
we had an array then we would have a
specification of of how to coordinate
asset with what so it's a bit like a
range so we have an array
and then we say
use these
mean max min max to coordinate
asymmetrics and then every element of
the matrix will become a triple of x y
comma value
called your position comma value sorry
wait a second sorry i missed something
here say that again
yes imagine we have in the first
argument matrix
of values and in the second it's a pair
x min x max and so so x mean x max y
mean y max
arrangement
x-men okay
arrange specifications so use uh two
pairs
okay
so this would return now
a matrix of triples
yeah i get it i get it it's it's
annotating with
it is annotating with the position i
mean it's something again which one
finds oneself you know one often says
map indexed
of
uh something like you know first of
hashtwo
comma hash
ampersand you know abcd
right
and then the third argument we had
planned was one in which we specify
whether we want a triple or a pair of
position comma value or an association
or a rule
this type of thing
by the way it might also be possible
well
maybe it's probably too early to say
whether this is possible but using some
of the um
rob's data container stuff it might be
possible to get something that
you know
would look just like this and you could
use you know lots of different functions
on it but which internally it wouldn't
actually have to make this big
expression
yeah that's a good idea
and you wouldn't have to call normal on
it to you know
or yeah if you get what i mean
uh right
um
so
okay so hold on so the the basic point
here we've got the concept
of
putting a wrapper
here that determines what gets fed into
it
or
and and perhaps these are
so you know the f of hash expression
comma hash position
could be provided both by this kind of
wrapper and by something which is a
wrapper on the expression
if i'm not mistaken or is that not the
case if the expression turned into a
list
no it still won't work will it work yes
it will work
if if we turn this into
okay
in this case right if if it turned out
if this meta if i thing
was i mean let's just write it if we if
we just say
um
map indexed
of
you know expression goes to
i hate that these are so long but anyway
expression goes to hash
index
goes to first of hash two
okay
and then we say like abcd
we get this and now what is the now what
we want to do
is to say we've now got our regular map
which says f of
a hash expression
comma you know hash index squared or
something
i see
so this so turning
if we had a function that simply turned
the thing we're applying ourselves to i
understand there's a multi-level issue
here if we had something which simply
turned it into this annotated
coordinate-ified form
then this would just work
right at level one
a level one but that would now would
that solve okay so in the select case it
would do the same thing would it would
just work
hold on but then but then what is select
you know if you're selecting over this
object i mean oh god yes
association yeah it returns the wrong
thing so it needs it needs both
sides of the transformation it needs to
transform into and transform out of
okay so that's a bit messier so that's
an argument for not having
that's an argument for addressing the
function
this is an argument if you have
well okay in in the case of
in the case of outer for example in the
wrap the f idea
outer could then decide that this is
position applied
of f
comma you know a b c d
and then g
actually inner would be a better example
here
that could be position applied and g is
is a naked function
it could also be
um
position applied so in principle every
function knows where it's being placed
and there is the corner case which is
the third point i was pointing out in in
the on the left which is what happens if
this position applied is used without a
wrapper
that's the case that confuses me
sorry say that again jose
what happens if we just evaluate
position applied of f of x this is not
wrapped by anything should it evaluate
to something do we consider that it's at
position empty list which is the
position of something in itself
so there is a corner case there which is
weird okay so position applied you're
saying
of f of x exactly should that evaluate
or not
and to what
so my feeling is that this should be f
of x empty list
but
that can be problematic for for other
things
that's a little weird but but you've
also commented that um
right that it escapes
could there be a stack position
um that's
kept by the evaluator related to stack
that this could just look at to figure
out where it was
my impression is that if it is a
function if position applied
is inside one of the key functions like
replace select map etc the function
itself will know what to do with it it
will convert it into something else
and so we don't let position apply
applied by itself do anything if it's
found in isolation then it only looks at
one level
yeah
but okay but let's just come back to
okay
position applied or index supplied or
whatever it is and perhaps both of those
are useful i mean index supplied
we could
the top use of this is going to be top
level so to speak first level
so index supplied would already be very
useful even without solving
the you know even without solving in
other words if we had map
of index supplied
of f
then we would have basically map index
functionality i know we'd have first
level map index functionality i suppose
um it's kind of icky that map indexed
gives this positional thing okay but
then
as opposed to
um
position applied of this expert comma
level three or something
right but if
oh right that that's not eating anything
so i guess that's okay
okay but i'm still concerned about what
other functions
we think are relevant to all of this
okay so so for example
fold
is fold relevant i mean you know could
we imagine something where we're saying
uh
you know if we have okay so we're
looking at other functions i i've wanted
to fold index a few times i think
like you know where you are in the list
yeah
i mean so this would be so is that
doable i mean in other words if we say
fold
a position applied
f
well this is one of the issues with um
well uh
well wait i mean so the the two issues
are that that it'll get applied to a
sequence
right
so is the position just like hash n plus
one where n is the number of things that
get passed into the position applied
and the other thing is that uh if if we
have this association-like case maybe
that's not how a physician applied works
but it's how the other meta stuff we're
talking about works i mean this is the
same as the issue with map thread i mean
what is the uh
uh
you know
you have hash hash and then you have
hash position i mean you can't have both
of those can you right so it's
yeah that's a nice yeah
i mean although
i mean you could have something like
hash expressions and maybe that can
evaluate to a sequence or it can
evaluate to a list or something like
that
um
[Music]
but but it means you can't write hash
right next to you write one of these
other things
i'm not completely convinced that hash
hash can't coexist with hash position
it can it cannot if we think of it
as
an as if association being fed in
it would be an association being fed in
right
well conceptually but it might not
actually be implemented that way which
might mean that hash hash could be a
could be sort of a partial thing that
doesn't pick up the extra meta arguments
in the association
it's kind of funky though i mean it's
funky yes yeah the other issue though is
with something like position applied
where at least so far we've been talking
about it you know it has hash one and
hash two but if you use it in map thread
you know
then it's it's hash one through n it
comes from the list where that n could
be anything and then plus one is the
position okay i get it okay so so the
issue is okay so map thread
has the problem that the f here can take
any number of arguments
and then the question is where does this
go so list one list two list three
um so the question is where does a
position argument for position applied
go
i have the impression that this is a bit
like when we do listability do we follow
an inner model an outer model we have
several possibilities so this is a this
is a design choice that would have to be
documented per function so here we
either append the position
of the final object
or we append individually the positions
of the individual lists which would be
of the same right which it reminds me
also of of the documentation of you know
color function or any of these other
things in graphics where they are fed
but i have to say i think that's worked
reasonably well
you know what i'm saying i mean the the
you know it it gets fed the x-coordinate
the y-coordinate the you know some other
thing etc right you'll you all know what
i'm talking about there
um
so okay so let's just look at a few
other ones here see what other things
there are
um
i mean fixed point would be amusing to
give it this
that would be a thing where it could
know
how many times it's iterated which
otherwise i don't even know how you do
something i mean in other words if it
says
uh well similar to the fold case that
seems quite useful
a fixed point position applied i mean
maybe we have to generalize the term
position applied of f
um you know if hash 2 greater than
100
you know g f g otherwise f
right but i mean
there's no easy way to do that otherwise
is that
probably not really but right it's also
weird right because you're
looking at
your thing that hasn't been positioned
in the expression you're looking at the
expression in this generated thing right
you're looking and this is something
that's going to come up in our
multi-computation design discussion
you're looking at
this in this case right the position
you know the position in this case
is created on the fly
it's not pre-existing
it's a bit like the position in the
fixed point list
so yeah we keep finding that it's either
the positioning input or perhaps the
position in output
that's correct
which we could imagine okay so
you know
that is also nest which i think is
probably even more common than fixed
point
yeah i agree
like nest indexed and things would be
you'd almost look like a like an
iteration applied
instead of position applied
well maybe that's a different function
maybe it seems like the goal here is to
not have 100 star indexed functions
uh but no no no no no but what bob is
saying is perhaps position applied
is
that that one is
position of the input position in the
input yes
whereas
iteration applied not the right name i
think but but you know
iteration applied is position in the
created output
i just think this is kind of a
fairly or
subtle distinction
implied
created output in the case of fixed
point
right
yes right i mean i
yeah i mean it may not be necessary yeah
to have this but what about functions
fold isn't off by one
for
ah sander is coming oh god that's right
yeah because he has the first
that's even worse fold right
fold
has these basically off by one
um
but you know i can imagine a bunch of
these like take while or you know a
bunch of these really being very happy
to have be able to pull in an index
sometimes
um i mean array is pre-indexed right
array is
array is specifically feeding in indices
um
let's see things like
okay so let's take a look at some of
these
um
subset map
oh boy
well that one
yeah i don't think that one is so
obviously
has a well
i mean it might have which of these yeah
in the association i mean
almost all these functions have nice
have nice nice ways you could do in the
association case like here you would
have you know position in the subset and
position in the input list and stuff
like that it's just different elements i
i think it's just the
if we're talking specifically about
position applied that is more troubled
right like in the harder cases if we're
giving a general association
you know you can you can change the keys
and you can have you know more
complicated stuff it's just that you
know
having it be the position with the
position applied is often not very well
defined
yes
okay well
let's just see on here
what other things
i mean you know one could imagine
accumulate
having an index
cumulate doesn't take a function though
oh you're right
forget that
forget it it's like moving map which
isn't on this list but
that's the general case
right in which case the position would
be
two elements
or you know many elements the window
size yeah it'd be the window
presumably but that's again complicated
yeah it complicates it is it the end
points of the window or the center or
what the span
yeah span expression
that's really weird you'd have to
pull apart
the span
okay if it's a pair of numbers it's kind
of ambiguous
if you talk about a position
that's true
um
what is ian sending through here
parafold what is this
so this was a response to a conversation
on some
mailing list uh fold taking the entire
list of elements seen so far instead of
just the next element
oh i see but isn't that like what fold
that's like what nest wild rather than
like an additional argument supplying a
different argument than what fold
normally gives so you have more
information
right which is what nest while and so on
do
fold does not have the apparatus that
nest while i mean things like
nest while
okay so for example if we look at nest
while
okay we've got all these things here
right which fold does not have that
possibility of a
larger window but sequence fold
does doesn't it
don't we have a fold while
[Music]
uh let's see but we have a sequence fold
which i have to admit i
have not used
i bet i should have used this
i bet the sequence fold
um
okay do we have a fold while
yes we do have a fold while which again
i haven't used
i probably should have used this
in a sense what we're suggesting here is
an alternative to having to remember
that the fold while exists
um
and instead
have some kind of
well would this thing that we're talking
about with position applied would it be
able to do the extra arguments a fold
while
is that obvious
well we can certainly invent some
notation that fall
sees and auto changes to fall while
but whether that can be generalized to
other functions it becomes
trickier you're thinking like a wrapper
on the f that would make it yes that's
what i'm thinking the
like the most recent m results
like that's
yeah that's something fold wild does but
it doesn't necessarily need to only be
fold while that has that capability
yeah but it's it's weird i mean look the
other thing if we're really going to
generalize the other thing is with map
or anything which recurses through an
expression
one of the things one doesn't have is
access to the essentially expressed the
tree stack above the the part that
you're in
see what i'm saying in other words if i
do a um
uh
like if i do this if i say map
if i
say f
slash at
um
you know h of of u of x comma
um
and let's just for
oh i don't know um
u of j of x and y
uh
then i will get this but those f's that
inner f there has no access to the fact
that it is being called inside a u of an
h or whatever
do you see what i'm saying
basically instead of only a position
you're talking about having really the
whole path
yeah right i mean in other words can
that be
what would that mean though i mean is
that not just the same thing as mapping
at a at a higher level or like a lower
level spec
no because because i hear but take into
account
something right but what does take into
account i mean how does it i mean how is
it going to tell you what the context is
without just providing that expression
well it could tell you the heads for
example it could be like the stack trace
oh i see you're saying you're saying
could there be a a a um
a hash you know head path or something
and maybe that's not useful
that's also called stack and if you do
stack inhibit of map of blah blah you
know and inside your f you call stack i
think it'll basically do what you're
saying
okay so include the f's in it if they're
you know if you're doing map all like
this it'll include the higher level f's
in it
but
okay but you're saying i mean what we
might be saying here is could you get a
u of
of uh uh whatever it is a a um
a list of uh
h of u
something like that
in other words this would be a way
if you wanted to implement up values in
slash dot effectively this would be the
way to do it
um
so
yeah we're gonna have to rap here in a
moment um
this is a really interesting discussion
and i think we've got it's clear okay
it's clear there's a
my guess is that
something like position applied and a
generalization of that
are going to be what we'll end up
finding will work and that will define
how it works
in particular functions
and that that's an alternative it's a
more factored way of not having you know
all sorts of
separately named functions
sandra is commenting that drop while
will be a useful thing to have
useful for
deleting headers
well that's interesting that's a good
point
yeah drop while
it's white space or something
it's a good point
well that's a reasonable thing for us to
consider having
people agree
um
okay
yeah there's actually from function
repository instance of it that we're
going to review at some point it might
be on the list here but yeah we'll look
at it another okay
um
all right we probably should wrap up
soon here unless unless somebody had a i
mean to me this is a
you know we've got more work to do and
in particular i think an important thing
i think this issue about metadata is
separate from the issue about
association returns
separate again from the parallel thing
which the parallel thing just seems to
me like it's going to be a headdress
anybody disagree about that
i mean maybe one point is that parallel
lies could be repurposed as a as a you
know headdress in addition to what it
already does or we could introduce a new
or you could say parallel applied or
something
yeah
we could say parallel applied of select
of whatever my my only my only
skepticism about parallel applied is
that it sounds a bit you know the other
functions that we have that have like
apply the name like curry applied and
operator applied or whatever they're
called
i mean those are those really take
anything and they're they're kind of
nothing
fair enough fair enough
parallelized you're suggesting that we
might redo re
that we might have i'm just saying i
mean we could have i mean the other
obvious one would just be parallel
but um
yes but but we could also just reuse
parallel eyes
i would say parallelized has not been a
grand success at this time
i mean parallelize in principle like
like because i just don't trust it i
don't know when it's going to work
and for example if we had parallelized
select and it gave me an error message
if there was no parallelization
available that would be more useful to
me or alternatively if the thing
had a syntax coloring
that made it clear that this just wasn't
going to work
by the way it does give a message of it
you know it says you know connect pearl
cannot parallelize this reverting to
unparallel sequential evaluation or
whatever
okay but so if i say
parallelize range of a thousand
something like this comma
um
uh you know prime q or something like
this
is that gonna do anything oh
oh no
come on
i always manually launch and kill the
kernels because
i don't like orphaned kernels running
around after this finishes
are there orphaned kernels
i thought there were i thought it
doesn't kill them because then that way
when you call
parallel map again it'll be fast oh yeah
yeah right no it doesn't kill the yes
but i mean
they can zombify
for example well the question is if you
kill this colonel if you kill this
monster colonel then they die yes
they're supposed to die they don't
always die
i've rarely seen them not die
i've certainly had cases where they
think
i had cases where they don't die but
um
okay now what did this do did this
parallelize well did it did it in fact
parallelize anything or did it just what
the hell did it do
anybody have any idea try calling
association map instead because i'm
pretty sure that one it won't
parallelize it and you can see what it
does
i mean the argument's the wrong order
but it doesn't matter
yeah
huh so you think it actually paralyzed
the select
i can't say for sure but i mean when uh
i don't think let me look at the
documentation i don't think it ever
gives you a list of what it can yeah
there's no list of what can parallelize
which is a little bit crazy that's crazy
i mean so so if i said here let's see
how could i do this i could parallelize
if i did a select how do i get the
machine name in here
um
you could just select um
well actually less than dollar kernel id
or something
or
why do you just echo the kernel id along
with the prime queue
okay
don't forget the ampersand after machine
look at that
what do you know
i had no idea all these years i had no
idea i've written all kinds of code
that you know sort of pre-prepares what
the hell wait a minute
wait a minute
i oh well no that's that's plausible
there were a thousand of those
i'm just want to try something else here
well so by the way another question
because i don't even this isn't even
more basically what paralyzed i don't
know does it always
i thought it like drilled into the
expression and tried to find stuff that
could parallelize but does it like if
you had f of select would it still work
by the way this example or some example
like this should be in the documentation
maybe reverse of select or something i
don't know
something at least evaluates
oh oh okay very fascinating i didn't
know that okay so it looks like it just
so it at least tries to look at it by
the way i would have thought compiler
technology should be able to assist this
greatly
uh
in what way
or being able to figure out from type
information
what might be parallelizable
oh okay actually this this is a more
deterministic function than i thought it
was because i thought that it it did
much more heuristic stuff drilling into
so did all expressions
so did i
i mean honestly i've i've never used
this function because i didn't trust
that it didn't a thing
it was supposed to be the be-all and
end-all function for parallelization
it just doesn't say what it paralyzes
just has no information here
the other thing that's a little
frustrating is that there are certain
parallel behavior that's only accessible
through parallel eyes like you know
like there's no parallel map indexed but
i think you can say parallelize with map
index and that works
you know
the thing that should happen at the very
least we should have some kind of syntax
coloring here
so that if you type parallelize off
select
because it's only going to work
lexically anyway basically i mean you
could feed it in with some weird you
know pattern matching and so on but
otherwise most of the time it's when
you're literally typing parallelize of
something
i mean we don't currently have we only
have discoloration if things fail we
don't have discoloration if they succeed
in other words it never goes more black
than black so to speak
that makes any sense but i could imagine
a situation in which
here
this somehow indicates that it is going
to work
i don't know if anybody has a can we
take that to the user assistance meeting
and and for goodness sake we've got to
get parallelized to at least document
what functions it works with what about
having it go lighter black grayish when
it won't work
that would be fine too
that would be nice
have the select gray out if it isn't
going to work
right
that would even turn like red but that
might be a little bit weird i don't
think it would because
if you had reverse of select the reverse
would be red
i'm not sure it wants to be read because
it could it well it's going to give a
message but it would work
i'm not sure that's a detailed question
but i think the first thing is to make
sure that we know and paralyze what
yeah because i mean this parallelized
functionality
is perfectly if if one could trust it it
would be perfectly reasonable and one
wouldn't need the headdress functions
what if you could get it to give you
back a report when it was done with like
a second argument and it says
you know this kernel x was used to do
this and colonel y was used to do that
well that that's basically
you know the analog of timing
for parallelization right
which is an interesting idea in its own
right
that is timing for example i mean i have
no idea what timing does when things are
parallelized what does timing do when
things are paralyzed
um if i say parallel evaluate of pause
of one
slash
absolute timing what the hell does it do
that just measures the clock time when
you start it when you finish it
yeah
oh i i see i see i see ics sorry i
should have been trying timing yeah
that's utterly mysterious
because
i mean this question of whether timing
i mean do we have any capability to
measure total cpu time
anybody know i mean that seems like an
important thing for our parallel stuff
to know what the total paradigm
there's a question of whether pause
should be counted as cpu time isn't
there i mean i don't think it's supposed
to be
okay fair enough
fair point
i mean is
so it's even more mysterious that's this
is that's absolutely that's absolutely
correct you know this is correct but
then what did this do
maybe it's point seven seconds of
overhead of something the overhead
exactly right and the overhead might be
multiplied by the different kernels
yeah
well so if i say timing here
what i'm gonna get
is
maybe you timing part two so you can
total of it in a minute
but again it might it might be the
yeah okay it might be the actual
operation apparel evaluating itself
what did i just do
part one not part two oh yeah
okay
so maybe do total apparel evaluate you
know slash last time
okay it's weird that the first one is so
much larger than the last one isn't it
that's the communication overhead
uh between the kernels i think right
that's the cpu time this kernel spent
sending out
receiving answers
yeah
which kernel spent the timings
no no the the
the first argument to
no no within the second argument output
within the second argument the values
are almost ordered and the first one is
so much bigger than the last one that's
what's freaking me out no
no
each sub kernel spent a fraction of the
second
cpu time doing positive one
the master okay seven whatever second
yeah and okay they're not exactly or
it's just different computers yeah that
that last one is is kind of large bob
yeah yes i gave it correctly that helped
that cleared everything up that
plot what does the plot mean it just
means it means that they're you have
different computers you have five
different computers with that many
kernels on each one right and different
facets
yeah so the last ones there might be
your local kernels or whatever yeah you
know
um but i guess maybe a question would be
so if if parallel eyes can just be
better documented so that you know you
know what it works on
is there's still value in having uh a
headdress maybe also called parallel
eyes possibly but i think let's start
off by by documenting it and see whether
we actually have decent coverage
and i think there is definitely missing
stuff like association map like i run
into missing stuff fairly routinely okay
but then then let's get it documented
let's get some kind of uh syntax
coloring feedback of whether it's going
to work
and that's a the place to start by the
way this will make a nice example of
somebody um for parallel evaluate
well i don't know exactly what wants to
do but this is kind of a cool thing
um
most people will not be able to
reproduce that plot locally
yes i realize that
the
um
uh okay
let's see and i i i need to run off
actually but but um uh
we need to continue this discussion and
maybe we should have a custom
slightly longer custom meeting
specifically about this um uh
position applied stuff
which i think we're going to be able to
nail i think it's going to be good
all right anything else quickly now
nope nope i think they think okay we'll
work on putting some together so i'm